so we're going to talk a little bit
about dna regulation and this is the
general idea that if you look at a
organism's genome that not all of the
genes are being transcribed and
translated at the same time it could
actually depend on the type of
cell that that that that dna is inside
of or it could depend on the environment
for that organism so for example if you
look at
say a multicellular organism
this maybe this is indices these are
over simplifications right over here
maybe this is some type of immune cell
immune
cell and let's say that this over here
is a muscle cell and they're not
necessarily are not likely to be these
perfect circles but this is just for the
idea
and they're going to have the exact same
dna
so the dna in both of these is the same
so dna
is
the same inside and these are going to
be these are eukaryotes so i'll draw the
nuclear membrane there same
dna
but they have very different roles
inside of this organism so it doesn't
make sense in fact
in order for them to even have different
structures they're going to have to
produce different proteins they're going
to have different
enzyme proteins inside of their inside
of their cytoplasm and so dna regulation
one way to think about it is well if
they have the exact same genome how do
they regulate which of those genes are
being transcribed and then translated
and which ones aren't and even if you
think about a unicellular organism right
here we have a bacterium and so it's
just one cell but even it will not want
to transcribe and translate all of its
genes at the same time for example
this over here
so this is it's this is the bacterial
chromosome
this right over here might be a gene
involved in the the digestion of a
certain type of food if that food is
present
this
type of and actually could even be
several genes that are involved in that
type of food and we will actually talk
going a little bit more
detail about when you have several genes
that are related and they tend to be
transcribed all at once or not
transcribed all at once so maybe that's
related to
digesting or consuming some type of food
maybe you have some genes over here that
are related to some type of stress
mechanism maybe it needs to go into
hibernation sometime and so if it's not
under stress it does not have to express
these genes but if it is under stress it
does have to express these likewise if
that thing that it needs to digest is
around it needs to transcribe these if
it's not around it does not need to
transcribe it so that's where how dna
regulation works whether you're talking
about a eukaryote or a prokaryotic organ
organism and so what we're going to do
in this video is focus a little bit more
a lot more on the prokaryote side
especially we're going to talk about
this bacterium
when we talked about
transcription in general in several
videos ago and in several videos we
talked about the idea of a promoter that
you have a gene that is a sequence of
dna that's part of the broader that's
part of the broader chromosome and we
said okay that rna polymerase needs to
attach some place
so that rna polymerase needs to attach
someplace and we called that place that
the rna polymerase attaches we call that
the promoter and then the polymerase
will transcribe the gene and when we
first talked about the idea of a
promoter we said and this is generally
true in eukaryotes that each each
promoter is associated with a gene or
each gene has a promoter but when we're
talking about prokaryotes and in this
case we're talking about this bacterium
it's actually typical to have multiple
genes grouped together that have one
promoter so the this promoter here and a
promoter is actually called a a
regulatory dna sequence let me write
this down so the promoter so that's this
part right over here that's the sequence
that is a that is a
regulatory
regulatory
dna
sequence
well that's what the rna polymerase
which i drew is this big blob
it's a protein here this big blob will
attach to and then it will begin to
transcribe all of these genes as a
bundle and when you have a promoter
associated with multiple genes that
combination of the promoter
and the genes and once again when i'm
talking about the promoters of the genes
i'm talking about sequences of dna that
combination is called an operon
this is called an operon it's a
combination of that regulatory dna
sequence which says hey rna polymerase
bind here so you can start transcribing
and the genes that it essentially
promotes the transcription
of and then of course that transcription
process takes that genetic information
in dna
transcribes it into messenger rna which
can then go with the ribosomes and we
have the whole translation process and
this should all be review to produce the
actual proteins that have functions
within or even potentially outside of
the cell
and so we're going to dig a little bit
deeper in is what can enhance this
process
make this happen more frequently or
things that might inhibit this process
in some way
so as i mentioned before this is just
what i had just drawn we have our big
rna polymerase blob and this is an
oversimplification for what it looks
like attaching to the regulatory dna
sequence which we call the promoter and
then it will do the transcription which
will produce mrna which can which
encodes the information in those genes
but what if we're in an environment
where we don't want to transcribe this
particular operon this particular
serie or maybe i should say this
particular series of genes
well then we might something in our
environment might
allow repressors to take action so what
are we talking about a repressor well a
repressor
a repressor right over here you see it
you see it attaching to a sequence of
dna after the promoter and so it blocks
it blocks the rna polymerase from being
able to do the transcription and so this
right over here this is a protein
that is called the repressor it's
literally repressing the transcription
and the regulatory dna sequence where it
attaches that is called the operator so
once again promoter was a regulatory
sequence where the where the rna
polymerase can attach and then the
operator is a regulatory sequence where
a repressor can attach and keep that rna
polymerase from actually being able to
perform the the actual transcription and
so
this this keeps the gene from from
keeping
continuing to to to transcribe and then
translate
these actual genes and you might even
have
extra mechanisms and you can even think
of them as feedback mechanisms
or ways to understand the environment
where the opera where the repressor i
should say this protein can only do its
job
can only so let's say that's its
repressor where it can only do its job
if it has other molecules that attach to
it
so maybe this one can only do its job if
it has another molecule attached to it
and in that case these smaller molecules
these are called co-repressors
co-co-repressor
repressor and we'll go into more detail
when we talk about things like the trip
operon
of how tryptophan and amino acid can
actually act as a co-repressor
now over here
we have the other way around where we
want even more transcription in that
case we would have something called we
would have an activator and
this
let me shade it in this dna right over
here this would be the regulatory
sequence where the activator binds and
so this would be positive feedback when
you have more activators you're going to
get more transcription while this would
would be and actually i shouldn't even
call it feedback because that implies
that somehow these products produce the
activator or these products produce the
repressor but that's not necessarily the
case it could be you could imagine that
case but it's not necessarily the case i
should just say that this is repressing
and this is activating it's going to
make more of the transcription actually
happen and just as we could have
co-repressors small molecules that you
could think of as activating the
repressor you can also have small
molecules that can turn the activator on
and these small molecules that turn the
activator on these are called inducers
so this right over here
these are inducers so this this protein
right here couldn't activate
that that operon but now that you have
these inducers and we'll study that a
little bit more when we think about the
lac operon this could be a a small sugar
of some kind well then it can turn on
the activation so this right over here
is called an inducer
so that's just a high level overview of
dna regulation as you can imagine this
can get very very interesting and
complex where you have your repressors
and co-repressors and activators and
inducers that might be dependent on the
environment that the cell is in what's
going on and it's in its broader
ecosystem there's all sorts of feedback
and feed forward loops that might be
going on and that's why the study we
could have the sequence and in fact we
do sequence entire genomes but even once
you have the sequence it's incredibly
complex to understand
all of these these loops of these
feedback and feed forward loops to
understand how these things actually
interact with each other